und wir kommen unserem nächsten fall wir
sind gangster gangster ihr seid pizza
oder blender das rap dieser junge hertha
18 karat und hat auf youtube allein auf
youtube damit 15 millionen klicks und 18
karat der weiß auch genau wovon er da
lebt denn er hat sich mit dem menüplan
eingelassen und gegen die minis wurde ja
schon wegen mordes wegen waffenbesitz
drogenbesitz und film weiteren ermittelt
auch deshalb hat die polizei in nrw
einer razzia gegen die führungsspitze
des amerikaners gemacht aber dieser mann
da der pate der bus der ist abgetaucht
alex talas und stefan sander wissen die
fahndung läuft
ste alias sam ihm ihren diesen namen hat
er sich wohl selbst gegeben um zu zeigen
dass er zu einem der berüchtigsten
klandt familien deutschlands gehört er
zeigt seinen 32.000 verloren bei
instagram was er unter einem angenehmen
leben versteht dicke autos fette partys
protz und prunk uhr
demiri ist untergetaucht sein haus in
dortmund verweist hier am phoenix see
ein nobelviertel in dortmund wohnt der
clan-chef seit märz fehlt von ihm jede
spur das bestätigen jedenfalls die
nachbarn sind luxus lamborghini mit
hagener kennzeichen soll er sich nach
spanien abgesetzt haben als dann ende
juni in maria die handschellen klicken
sollten weil abgetaucht seitdem fehlt
jede spur
ende juni führen polizei und
staatsanwaltschaft eine groß angelegte
razzia unter anderem in dortmund und
bochum gegen den amerikaner durch der
vorwurf kokainhandel mit mehreren kilo
wir gehen davon aus dass wir mit dem
einsatz im heutigen tage wirklich einen
schlag in dem bereich des musikladens
vollziehen konnten wir gehen davon aus
dass wir wirklich die obere
führungsebene
zumindest in teilen festnehmen konnten
so dass es ein großer erfolg für uns als
polizei
doch plant chefs amiri war den
ermittlern durch die lappen gegangen
amiri soll nach angaben der
staatsanwaltschaft dortmund mit
rauschgift im großen stil gehandelt
haben an beweisen mangelt es nicht
allein 40.000 chat nachrichten wurden
entschlüsselt und dokumentieren die
kokain geschäfte mit einem
internationalen haftbefehl wird nach dem
clan chef gesucht der vorwurf
bandenmäßiger handel mit drogen
miri und die rapper mit dem gangster
rapper 18 karat hat er ein eigenes
musiklabel gegründet im handelsregister
finden wir bei den namen unter dem
eintrag von zu primus music wollte mir
damit seine illegalen drogengeschäfte
verschleiern wir fragen seinen
geschäftspartner an doch von 18 karat
gibt es keine stellungnahme
diese länder wir sind nicht so weit
in den letzten jahren hatte es immer
wieder auseinandersetzungen
verschiedener rapper im ruhrgebiet
gegeben hatte und sein clan ihre finger
mit im spiel bei einer razzia im
vergangenen jahr rückt die polizei schon
einmal mit panzerwagen und
spezialeinsatzkräften an
der mini lässt es sich derweil offenbar
weiter gut gehen aus der ferne verhöhnte
seine verfolger weiter mit ports bildern
bei instagram
ja und über diesen fall wollen wir
natürlich weiter sprechen und den
analysieren mit unserer achtung fahndung
expertin sandra schmidt schön dass sie
da sind ehemalige dienststellenleiterin
der polizei und dort hunderte beamte
geführt und soll dass sie da sind und
wir wollen gleich darüber sprechen wer
mit so viel über clowns gehört was
spricht denn die polizei von
kleinkriminalität
ja das schwierige an der sache ist dass
es keine bundesweit einheitliche
definition gibt was kleinkriminalität
als solches ist es gibt aber bestimmte
indikatoren an denen man es fest machen
kann ob man es mit dem thema zu tun hat
oder nicht das sind zum beispiel
klassische
patriarchalische führungsstrukturen in
diesen familien
es ist sind abschottungstendenzen also
eine mangelnde integrationsbereitschaft
eine regionale konzentriertheit und
natürlich große marktpotenziale
bedrohungspotenziale die dann auch
eingesetzt werden um in den
kriminalitätsfeldern zu agieren jetzt
wenn wir hier auf das bild hinter uns
gucken da sehen wir eben diese unheilige
allianz von gangsta rappern und clans
warum gehen die clans dieser allianz ein
wir beobachten nicht nur allianzen mit
rappern beispielsweise die insbesondere
weil diese menschen im fokus der
öffentlichkeit stehen im in den medien
präsent sind wir beobachten allianzen
mit rockern auch in einzelfällen mit
extremisten es geht meistens um status
erhöhung um einen image-gewinn es geht
um bündnisse um koalitionen also man
macht sich konkurrenten zu verbündeten
und es geht immer darum
netzwerkstrukturen zu stabilisieren zu
schaffen und diese dann zu erhalten also
es geht eigentlich um macht jetzt wollen
wir einmal schauen die miri sie haben
gesagt regionale konzentration aber das
besondere gerade an den mir es ist ja da
gibt es also diesen stützpunkt in bremen
und dann aber auch klare strukturen in
bremen in berlin und auch in dortmund im
gesamten ingesamt nrw eigentlich wie
kommt dass das eine familie so mächtig
so stark werden kann wenn wir über clans
clan großfamilien sozusagen sprechen
dann dürfen wir nicht die traditionellen
familienstrukturen die wir vielleicht
vor augen haben
ansätzen es geht es sind eigentlich
menschliche organisationen es sind es
gibt eine kernfamilie und um diese
kernfamilie schaden sich akteure die
gleiche ziele und interessen haben wie
diese kernfamilie mich alle diese
akteure sind zwingend miteinander
blutsverwandt das ist also ein großes
netzwerk kann man sagen ein
strategisches netzwerk und das macht
diese familien so mächtig auch also sie
agieren in netzwerkstrukturen sehr stark
organisiert und sie besetzen halt
themenfelder kriminalitätsfelder die in
überwiegendem maße der organisierten
kriminalität zuzuordnen sind also sie
agieren auch konspirativ verdeckt ohne
dass lange zeit eine entsprechende
staatliche intervention gab also ich
zitiere kurz den minister aus nrw der ja
deutlich betroffen bis 2019 ein
interview wenn der sagt wir haben es
verpennt dann wissen wir mit bis zu tun
haben vielen vielen dank frau schmidt
dass sie da waren und uns auch am ende
leider diese bittere analyse mitgebracht
haben dankeschön gern und natürlich
fragt die polizei in nrw wo steckt denn
nun der meere clan-chefs amiri polizei
und staatsanwaltschaft suchen den 35
jährigen dortmunder mit kurdisch
libanesischen wurzeln mit einem
internationalen haftbefehl wegen
kokainhandels im großen stil seit ende
juni wird nach ihm gefahndet zuletzt
orteten ihn ermittler im spanischen
marbella und samt schwarzen lamborghini
mit dem amtlichen kennzeichen
hsm 47 hat sich soeben abgesetzt
hinweise an die polizei dortmund unter
132 0